jedd more light on this is former
assistant director of the FBI bill Gavin
bill it's great to have you on tonight
you were called out by the way by Ken
Delaney and which we will play in a
moment but your reaction to where we
stand now with the drumbeat is his
incessant drumbeat for FBI involvement
bill Laura I just I am amazed that this
whole thing number one everybody's
calling from an investigation an
investigation of what there is no
predicate offense for the federal
government in the form of the FBI to
conduct any investigation an
investigation of if there was a rape or
a sexual assault should have been done
by local authorities and everybody knows
that the statute of limitations has run
on that now number that's that's number
one number two background investigations
it's over it's done now could the White
House conceivably say we'd like you to
open it up again they could but it's not
going to happen in this particular case
what what could come from opening the
background investigation again we go out
and interview who number one the alleged
victim has off been offed by senator
Feinstein wishing produced a heavily
redacted letter that really hints at
something that nobody knows what
happened number two
judge Kavanagh has already given his
point of view number three his friend
has already alleged it I have no
knowledge of anything like this not what
I think that Judge Gavin Oh would do
anything like that this just what they
tried to do is put the FBI at a jackpot
it's a no-win situation for the bureau
you go out and nothing is found they're
going to say you didn't do your job
you're only supporting the the
contention I gotta say Kendall a nyan
from NBC it took it took you to task on
on that analysis I want to play it for
you and then bill get you to react on
the other side let's watch my sources
are frankly presenting another view than
the one you just heard from Bill Gavin
which is that the FBI absolutely could
investigate this not as a criminal
matter but as part of their role
background checking federal nominees
they could only do that if the White
House asked them to look into this
allegation and if the White House did
ask them to do that they would be
perfectly capable of shedding some light
on this so this is the rub it's it's the
president always goes back to President
Trump if President Trump really cared
about women and to protect women and
cared about sexual assault allegations
he would demand that the FBI I guess go
back and you know again find every house
with a pool and Chevy Chase Maryland or
something and then try to get these old
Georgetown Prep kids to rack their
brains about you know some keg party 36
years ago but they're trying to put this
on Trump is there any validity to that
point
no there is no validity to that point at
all what he says every you could dig up
who are you going to dig there's nobody
that can tell you anything at this
particular point in time and then he
said something about the fact that you
could put them under oath you don't put
anybody under oath in a situation like
this you obtain the facts feed them to
the White House it to the Congress and
let them do what they want it's you know
it just seems to me that's all we're
trying to do is delay the vote and do it
any way they possibly can I probably
shouldn't be sitting here saying that
but that's the exact way I feel and
that's bill I think it's it's the way a
lot of Americans feel tonight and thanks
so much for being here